♪If there's some medication ♪
♪ I could take ♪
♪ To make me want to hate you ♪
♪ And kill this ache ♪
♪ If there's some medication ♪
♪ I could take ♪
♪ You know I would do it ♪
- Woo. What?
♪ They don't got a pill for this ♪
- You better shut up
- Yo.
♪ They don't got a pill for this ♪
(boisterous applause)
- Oh my god.
Please welcome singer,
songwriter, Sam DeRosa, ya'll.
(boisterous applause)
(applause drowns out voices)
- Come on in.
- How are you?
(mumbles)
- Patricia Heaton.
- Nice to meet you.
- Hi, I'm Sam.
- Okay.
- Woo, I'm already crying.
- Okay, well, first of all, welcome.
Secondly, I was not kidding.
I don't know if you read
the card back there,
but my sister, because it was the pilot,
I guess they kept showing sneak previews
of songs or something.
My sister has been all over me
and I kept forgetting to ask Shane.
She loves your song "Pill for This".
She was like, where's the girl,
and then it didn't even,
I just want the song.
She was just so glad it came it out.
And she literally said,
"I don't want somebody else to sing it.
I want her to sing it."
- And that's what we got.
So, that was amazing.
- Yes.
So are you kind of happy
that you didn't win
and it's all, I'm being serious.
Like you didn't win and it's
all unfolding beautifully.
- Honestly, I feel like I won.
Do you know what I mean?
Sometimes I feel like there's
no right way all the time
to do things.
There's no perfect way
and my whole life has been a series
of being told there's a door
and me finding my way in through a window.
Really, has been forever and I've--
- There's a song.
- Get it, get it.
- And you know what,
we're sitting right here.
- Do you want to sing it?
- I just want to be a part in the room.
I don't have to be a part
of any one word, one third.
I just want to be there.
No, it's fun to write with him.
He's incredible as well.
- He really is.
- [Kelly] He really is.
I'm amazing and I love awards.
(laughs)
- I saw that.
It said I love trophy.
- I know he's awesome.
- Look at my little trophy.
(boisterous laughter)